teaching from mastery learning means
that teachers only move on to the next
subject once everyone has mastered a
current unit in other words there's no
good enough only perfect traditionally
we set a fixed amount of time to study a
unit and allow for flexible outcomes for
example one year of basic algebra
returns students with grades from A to F
teaching for mastery turns this around
all students attain an a even if it
requires more than a year for example a
math teacher ensures that everybody
knows how to compute addition before
going on to more difficult units such as
multiplication or division this prevents
growing knowledge gaps and increases
unity among classmates with no one left
behind teaching for mastery demands
perfection if you asked at what
temperature does water start boiling
don't accept 100 dig deeper until the
student replies that the boiling point
of water depends on the atmospheric
pressure which changes according to
elevation at sea level it is 100 degrees
Celsius but it boils at a lower
temperature in higher altitudes teaching
for mastery requires clear learning
goals detailed tracking students
progress and diverse opportunities to
catch up for those who fall behind some
schools even reorganize classes by the
students level of understanding instead
of age if you are interested to learn
more about this method please check out
the links in the description and let us
know in the comments how you can see it
applied in class the Khan Academy orgy
features great examples on how to set
clear learning goals with its knowledge
map and study videos for students who
need to catch up or releasing videos
regularly so don't forget to subscribe
and like us on Facebook thank you for
watching